。
今天咱们讲的是星旧崛起啊，星旧崛起这部片子非常值得学习，它是。
2011年的片子吧，应该是啊。
非常值得我们所有同学去学习。因为。
我待会儿讲完你就知道了啊。
他可以。
啊，让我们学会一种。
非常大类型的故事的写法啊，而且这个故事呢非常的教科书啊，非常的教科书，非常的严谨啊非常严谨。因为它是一部。
致敬的影片啊，只要有点致敬一些经典的。
致敬一些经典。
所以说这部片子呢大家看的时候肯定是会觉得很很顺畅，甚至嗯该扎心的时候扎心，该该该震撼的时候震撼。那么我们今天就通过今天的课程来了解一下呃，两件事情。第一件事情是这部片子。
他为什么？
让我们觉得好看。
二呢是。
我们要学会写这类片子，以后出现这类片子，我们就不慌了啊，出现这类片子我们就不慌了啊。来废话不多说啊，先。
拉信息节拍啊，拉出他的信息包了以后，你才能确定这部片子它是个什么类型，它的启程转合在哪里，甚至你才能确定这个片子是主角，配角怎么谁是伙伴，谁是爱情是怎么安排的，明白吗？然后这部片子呢是有前史的啊，是有前史的，而且前史就占据了十几分钟。
所以会影响故事打点啊，我在课程上讲过啊，如果有前史，你要特别注意，要从现状开始算啊，第一分钟啊第一分钟。
在丛林里抓星星啊，前十的第一拍啊，期在丛林一场捉星星的动作戏啊，然后其中有一个星星啊，或者有一批星星吧被迫离开了家乡，被抓走了啊，被抓走。
然后第二拍就是从第三分钟开始，其中有一只绿眼睛的猩猩啊，r eye表现出了比较高的智商啊，超高的智商。威尔就是那个小帅啊，有些同学说主角叫小帅，小帅认为实验很成功啊，决定向董事会申请人体实验啊，申请人，而且。
而且还专门强调这个实验的重要性，这是一次千载难逢的机会啊。
这里我们说讲前史或者故事的第一幕啊，启程转合的起加上前史一般都会比较信息比较密集。因为要往前推故事，特别是这种故事。因为这种故事呢它的设定比较强啊，比较强的设定。
然后第三拍就第五分钟董事会提案啊，然后展示这个实验效果啊，能治疗啊子海默呀。
那就是各种接近比要成功了的时候，结果这个名眸呢发狂了啊，发狂了呃惨死被打死后达了这个会啊后我们的小帅被打脸然后第四拍进到第8分钟事情失败之后，所有的星星啊，所有的星星都要被杀死啊，呃要收拾这个烂摊子啊，人道处理安乐死这些星星。
这里我们的主角啊主角小时候登场，我们说前十嘛，前十肯定是讲主角的前十呀，他就是这个名眸的。
儿子啊，他与我们的另外一个男主，或者我们暂时先算不算他是男主啊，就是威尔，也就是小帅啊，他与小帅第一次相识。
相遇啊，记住啊，感情啊，如果是你从虚旅情的角度去捋这个脉络的话，这里有一个相遇啊，两个人相遇，而且相遇我说东西是要有仪式感的相遇，记不记得啊？感情八个节拍相遇就相识，这里是要有仪式感的，他们的仪式感非常明确，他负责安乐死这个幼崽。
但是呢他下不去手，他其实本来应该给这个。
幼崽注射针剂安乐死啊，但是他下不去手啊，你看这个相食就很有意识感。
然后第五拍呢其实在第1111分钟左右了啊，就威尔回到家啊，先交代一下家庭的环境。他父亲呢有病情啊，父亲有病情，有个困境啊，有病情啊，其实就是阿尔兹海默，这也是他坚持原因坚持研究阿尔兹海默特效药的一个动因。然后这里呢。
凯撒与另外一个伙伴啊与另外一个伙伴也也做了一个相识，就是他父亲啊就是他父亲。
小帅的父亲啊，威尔的父亲相当于是凯撒的爷爷啊，然后呢各种照顾他啊，各种照顾他。
而且起了个名字啊，给他给他起了个名字叫凯撒。
是爷爷给他赐名的啊。
然后在这里，凯撒和家庭产生了感情的羁绊，也展现了自己的高智商以及绿色的眼睛。也就是说他遗传了母亲的优秀的基因。
在这里啊前十就结束了啊，结束了以后进入故事的第一幕，也就是第六拍，人家直接用旁白告诉你的，三年后嘛，采桑长大了。
展现出了。
超高的智商，甚至比同龄的孩子还聪明，这很正常啊。因为星猩的成熟期比较短，所以比同龄的孩子聪明也是很正常。
然后第七拍。
第七拍展现家庭的困境啊，就是。
父亲的病情越来越重啊，而且已经逐渐失控了。
你像这种节拍，你写不写都可以啊，但是因为我要讲课，所以我给。
我给大家先都列出来啊，然后第八。
也是第16分钟啊，威尔回公司拿实验药品给父亲注射啊，因为这是一条比较重要的浮线吧，所以说我们单独把它拎出来。但是有些同学拉的节拍比较少的，可能是把浮线给去掉了啊，也没问题也没有问题。
然后在这里呢。
发现了父亲。
恢复了记忆和理智，对吧？病好。
这是第九拍。然后第十拍呢。
凯撒开始羡慕其他小朋友的玩具啊，开始羡慕其他小朋友的玩。
第一次偷偷跑出家门，惹怒了邻居啊，这个邻居还是个挺重要的配角啊，惹怒了这个邻居发生了争执好吧。然后第十一拍。
也就是第20分钟啊，一个经典镜头。
带着凯撒路过动物园，这场戏后面是要兑现伏笔的啊，凯撒什么都记得。
带着凯撒路过动物园，我再强调一遍，这是个经典镜头。为什么经典镜头呢？因为这个镜头像极了，记不记得我带你们看过绿皮书啊，绿皮书有一场车坏了，修车的戏，记不记得？
主角看着自己的同类，在棉花地里老作。
就然看着自己的同类。
在动物园里啊这场戏经典镜头。
然后呢路过动物园，因为动物园啊，因为动物园后面也要兑现这个伏笔。
当然去动物园还有一件事情要办，所谓的女主角啊登了一下场啊，这个女兽医登一下场。但其实算不上女主角啊，因为不管是从戏份上，还是从剧情推进上还是从感情线上，他都算不上女主角啊，但是没有办法啊，一般来说都是这么去就是外行人会这么去解释啊，这这么去去去解读。
咱们自己要知道，他就是个连个伙伴都算不上。
然后第十二拍也就21分钟，女兽衣来到维尔家做客啊，然后嘞。
呃，我们就这里要看到记一下这个女兽医的作用啊。我们说在这时候在有一些视就刚费解或者是流程复杂的电影的时候，我们会需要一个解说员，就是你这个片子啊如果比较费解。
就是里面有很多道导要讲，你这时候需要一个解说员，这个女兽医就完美诠释了。她其实主要来不是跟小帅谈恋爱的。你可以这么理解，跟小帅谈恋爱是一个非常不重要的事儿。他其实是来解说的，对于我们故事来说啊，因为她懂这个动物的相关知识。
同时，由于他会解说，他可以进行一些预言，比如说这种人兽共处的和谐场景是不会持久的。他要这个男主角提前做好思想准备啊，这作用是非常有用的。
然后第3趴22第22分钟，非常重要的一场戏。大家带着凯撒去红森林公园玩，也就是去那个红山树林去玩啊。
凯撒在获取了小帅的喜这个这个许可以后。
开始释放自己的野性啊，然后呢有异族王太奇啊，又过去了好几年。
他又长大了一些。
但是衣服和项圈一直没有改变。在这里大家记得啊，这里有一组蒙太奇镜头啊，配着BGM。
然后嘞，凯撒长大了又是好几年。所以。
所以有一些同学。
会把。
前十。
打到这儿。
也就是说22分钟的前时。
不止22分钟。
20得有25分钟的前时。
嗯，我也没有问题啊，我也没有问题。你如果把前十打点打到这儿，认为从这里进入第一幕，我也同意再次强调啊，所谓的分类，所谓的打点。
都是事后总结的归纳理论，不是。
不是不能突破的。在这里，当然男呃这个威尔和这个女医生已经开始谈恋爱了啊，好几年过去了嘛。
然后在这一场戏。
也就是说，在这一次，他们同从。
这个红杉树公园回去的时候，也就是来到了第十4第十4拍啊，26分钟。
海撒遇到了一只宠物狗，大家记不记得啊一个灯一个黑背啊，都有个大大大狼狗。
然后双方产生了攻击性啊，开始。
开始对吼。
然后凯撒开始怀疑自己的身份。
他对自己的项圈和锁链产生了抵触，而且这里有一个非常有趣的细节。
非常有趣的细节。
凯撒原本是做后备箱的啊，他本来是一直做后备箱的，但是他今天他非要做后座。
为什么？
为什么要做后座啊？这里啊威尔已经给他把。
后备箱拉开了，他不做。
这里他开始对自己的血脉和身份正式提出质疑啊，也就是说他对现状开始不满啊，明白吗？所以有同学愿意把第一幕从这一场戏开始也是没有问题的。
我待会儿说为什么这一幕也是没有问题的啊，因为他也是在丛林开场，没有问题。有些同学愿意第一幕从这里开始，没有问题啊。但是这个戏的前十确实很长啊，然后第十五拍啊等于是第十四拍才进入正题啊，进入正题。你可以理解前面十三拍全是前十，第十5拍威尔带着凯撒。
来到公司啊，来到公司寻根，告诉他他的身世以及他的母亲的问题。
啊，以及他为什么呃与众不同，这其实也是一个伏笔啊。然后第16拍，也就是第29分钟，这个女医生开始发挥作用了，她开始质疑这件事情啊，也提出凯撒的这个处境问题，也预言再次预言凯撒注定无处安放啊。
第十七拍30分钟啊30分钟吃早饭啊，父亲的病情又开始发作，甚至加倍发作了啊，因为这个困境开始发力。
然后第十八拍，当然你可以跟十7拍合在一起啊。第十八拍。
父亲的发病。
然后呢，导致他出去开车，而且开的是别人的车发生了车祸，跟邻居发生了争吵。这个邻居又来了啊，邻居发生了。
然后凯撒为了保护自己的爷爷或者自己的亲人和人。
正式发生冲突啊，失控了，而且咬伤了对方啊，把大家都吓坏了。
然后第1九派，也就是第33分钟，凯撒呢被动物管理局抓走了啊，威尔和女医生去解救他也没有没有没有成功啊，没有成功。而呃穿着衣服啊，凯撒穿着衣服被威尔尔亲手送进了动物管理局。
然后呃凯撒在不知情的情况下啊，威尔呢离开了离开了，凯撒第一次感受到了委屈啊，感受到了委屈和背叛吧，感受到了委屈。
然后进到第二幕啊，也就是启橙爪合的成啊，进到第二幕之后，第二0拍，也就是第37分钟，凯撒开始了自己痛苦的监狱生活啊，监狱生活。
什么坏的狱警呀、不友善的狱友呀，这种监狱系的标准标配，监狱系的这些标配都给都都上了啊，标监狱系标配什么被水冲呀，没有好东西吃呀，浴霸欺负人呀，狱警是黑狱警啊，这都都都整上了啊，都整上了。
相当于是。
游戏时间啊游戏时间。
然后第38排这个威尔呢就是再把这个男配角或者说这个男2号威尔再捞一捞啊，他还并没有放弃啊，他并没有放弃他在上诉。但是呢什么牵绊他呢？
他的父亲的病情呀快速恶化，所以他确实也是走投无路啊，分声不响啊。所以说这个另外一个男二号啊稍微往回找吧找吧。
然后呢，这里由于监狱戏确实是没有什么太多可拍的，所以把视角一定程度给了这个威尔了啊。
第22拍还是他39分钟，威尔再次去找到他的上司啊，透露自己呃偷偷在父亲上做实验。
然后申请继续研究。上司当然开始觉得你好大胆，但是同意他继续做实验。因为看到了。
这个有利可。
然后第23拍第41分钟，凯撒啊在监狱嗯，因为反抗那些呃浴霸被人虐打啊，被人打，被被预警浴霸都打。
孤丹很可怜，这里搞了一个名场面啊，在墙上画了一个窗户，也就是这场戏还是非常感人的啊。凯撒在墙上画了一个窗户的形状，他想回家在这里记着啊。
他想回家。
回家。
回什么？
他想回到人类的怀抱，记着啊，这里回家代表他还在想回到人类的怀抱。
然后第二4排。
第二4排，也就是第43分钟啊，实验确实重新开启了，而且呢。
找了一个科巴啊，科巴那个在后面的系列，在这个后面的系列里面发挥了比较重要的作用啊。这里其实就是选了一只呃也很聪明的猩猩科巴啊注开始注射113号药物啊，凯撒的母亲注射的是112号。
然后第25排凯撒呢？
再次啊尝试接触同类，但是被视为另类啊，被排挤，被欺负啊。刚才被虐打是被被狱警虐打，这里才是被同类虐打啊呃被视为被排挤，被欺负，被殴打，而且标志性的衣服也被扯掉了啊，标志性的衣服也被扯掉了。这场衣服被扯掉，你想你什么啊？
有没有想起霸王别姬啊？
小豆子烧掉棉大衣。
家庭或者是与母亲的保护彻底决裂。
小豆子在霸王别姬里面烧掉棉大衣，我们说那是那是小豆子个人旅程里面与母亲的保护彻底决裂，或者是讲与家庭的保护彻立。
他在这里是被动的，他的衣服被扯掉了啊，然后最后还被麻醉枪打打。
这场戏啊是他被同类欺负殴打。
然后第26拍也就是第47场啊第47场。
另外一边的实验啊，就是威尔那边那2号那边啊实验很成功。
那个星星展现出了高智商，还会写字呢。嗯，但是助手啊助手开始有副作用，这个是一条是一个小小的悬疑啊，悬疑线不是小于悬疑线嘛，信息差啊信息差大家都不知道这件事情，副手副手由于误吸了113。
呃，开始有副作用了，这是一个小学的悬念线。
嗯，在后面一集当中，在第二步当中有作用。在第一步当中其实作用不大啊，这里是个悬念，但是作用不大。
第27排啊49分钟。
凯撒。
开始啊凯撒开始。
交朋友了啊，交到了自己的一个朋友，那个红毛星星啊。
呃，埋下了复仇的伏笔吧。
开始交第一个朋友了。
然后这时候男女主再次来看望凯撒啊，发现凯撒受伤了啊呃威尔想带走凯撒，暂是没有成功。
凯撒。
非常的失望。
非常的生气。
他在这里。
擦掉了自己画的那个窗户。我刚才说那个窗户是什么，标志着是代表什么？
除了代表家庭以外，还代表什么？
代表他想回到人类的怀抱。
那么在这里。
他擦掉了这个窗户，代表什么呢？
他想与旧的自己。
彻底决裂啊，我们说这就是故事终点了。啊，那故事终点，我们说第一个目标放弃了，是不是要调整目标，记不记得啊？我说在故事终点的时候，是不是要调整目标啊，他之前的目标是什么？他之前的目标是想回家换目标了啊。
好，进入第三幕第28场第28个节拍。
52分钟。
凯撒啊开始观察形势，酝酿新的计划。我们说这场戏比较重要啊，虽然很短，但是我们单拿一排，为什么呢？因为它是一个新的开始啊，新的开始，因为他开明确的开始酝酿酝酿新计划了。然后第29拍也就是第53分钟，这时候好死不死啊，那个管理员带了几个人来来来看。
来看星星啊，而且还在那显摆自己的暴力。
大意了啊，凯撒趁机偷走了一把瑞士军刀啊，趁机偷走了一把瑞士军刀。
然后第30拍来到第55分钟，凯撒利用这个军刀呢逃出了自己的房间，去找了那个最强壮的银背大猩猩啊，同时呢又引出了自己的仇家啊。
呃利用这个淫被大猩猩和他的智慧啊，打服了对方，成为了啊呃驯服了对方。
成为了小的小的首领吧啊，成为了小的首领。我们说在这里他凯撒还是非常有策略的啊，攻克了三个人，最聪明的红毛猩猩用语言沟偷是吧？最最强壮的银贝达猩猩解决对方的困境是吧？然后又。
把最刺儿头最凶悍的一个。
呃，用暴力制服啊用暴力制服用三种方法。
呃，把这个星猩团队三个最有代表性的人物分别拿下啊。
然后来到第。
31排也就是第57分钟啊，威尔继续给父亲用药啊，两个人就父亲已经啊非病非常重了。
呃，然后。
呃，第二天早上啊，父亲离开了父亲离开了，就说威尔还在想，当然了，还是要救一下威尔的人设啊，威尔还在想念凯撒。
第32拍啊第32排威尔回到公司和老板就新要的策略产生争执。他是不推他是不同意量产的，他觉得还得再试。
但是老板呢执意要量产啊，这这还是为第二步去做复笔。
然后第33拍啊呃威尔是对的啊，威尔是对的。呃，那个之前那个工作人员发病了啊，发病了，甚至都吐血了。
然后第三4拍啊，来到第612分钟，威尔去贿赂动物收容所要把凯撒带走啊，早这样不就好了吗？对吧？但是故事他不能早这样，他拿钱去贿赂那个园长，那个园长同意他把凯撒带走。
但是。
凯撒自己把门关上了。
他决定留下。
他和人类的家庭做了切割。
但是赢得了同伴的尊重，对吧？这里有两个小细节，他为什么把门关上啊？两个原因，一个是他的好朋友。
的代表那个红毛猩猩在看着他呢。
第二。
他看到了。
威尔来接他。
手里拿着什么？
手里拿着。
那个那个那个链子对吧？锁链。
手里拿着锁链。
然后呢。
他意识到啊他意识到。
自己。
还是。
不平等对吧？依然不平等，对吧？依然没有。
不可能成为一个人类啊。
但是他通过留下赢得了同伴们的尊重。
然后第35拍也就是64分钟。
凯撒开始给大家发发甜筒发甜头。
发饼干是吧？这这团队管理这个呃给个打一棒子给个甜枣是吧？用食物驯化团队，用食物驯化团队啊，用实物驯化团队，而且而且还有自己的理论，强调团结的力量啊，强调团结就是团结的重要性。一个筷子很容易掰断，一把筷子就掰不断。
是吧。
然后第36拍也就是第66分钟，凯撒越狱了啊，呃，他回家啊，其实他回到原本人类的家庭嗯。
回来当然看了看他曾经的父亲威尔。
但是他其实并不是因为想家才回来。
他是回来拿药的，因为他有更大的计划，他偷走了实验用药，在这里还有非常有意思的小细节。凯撒这家伙还是很调皮的。
这里有一个小细节。
注视着他的曾经的。
父亲。
还是有感情的对吧？但是呢主要是回来偷药的，偷完药临走的时候，把邻居的车又给踩爆了，还是很记仇是吧？还是很记仇，没有完全没有这个必要，是吧？引起骚动，这报警警警报响了，这个其实还是很危险的，对吧？但是他他不行，我得我得搞一下子。
然后他回去了之后呢，用这个药物激发了团队所有人的智慧啊，他这个偷了药回去之后把大家都变成绿眼睛了，呃，拥有了智慧，甚至开始开始开会了啊，甚至开始开会了。
就星星们开始开会了，记不记得？我给大家讲过人类简史。我说这个智人当时为什么干掉尼阿尼安德特人，是因为智人会开会，明白吗？
所以他们开始开会了啊，开始仿照人类一样，开始开会了。然后来到第37拍，也就是第71分钟，这个药品呢开始批量生产的同时，之前那个工作人员也暴毙了啊，为第二季去埋伏笔。然后第38拍凯撒带着大家正式造反啊，正式造反。
在这个监狱就是开始闹啊，开始这个监狱暴动啊，而且还第一次开口说话。第一次开口说话，这里大家记得吧？相当震撼，记不记得这场戏啊？这场戏是不是特别震撼啊？
有。
同样还是这一拍第38拍第72分钟这里。
他们把这个管理员打败了啊，把管理员打败了，然后还把这些人关进了监狱，啊，他们的团队全都释放出来了啊。在这里有一个非常重要的信息，星星们想啊想要杀死一个管理员啊，猩星们想要杀死一个管理员，但是被凯撒给阻止了。
被凯撒给阻止了。
然后另外一个管理员要拿电攻击凯撒，凯撒拿水冲他啊，误杀了另外一个管理员啊，误杀了。也就是说另外一个管理员当然也死有余辜了。
但是这里一个重要的信息是什么呢？就是凯撒不想杀人。他作为一个主角啊呃不能这么快杀人，确实不能这么快杀人。虽然虽然大家背叛了他，虽然大家欺负他啊，最好不要那么快杀人啊，因为这种片子啊。
杀杀杀人有点早啊，来故事来到第四名啊，第39排，凯撒军团啊向着药厂进军啊。同时呢威尔也发现了凯撒已经越狱了啊。
呃，包括警方也都介入了进来啊，警方也都介入了进来。
然后第40排从78分钟开始，凯撒军团军团袭击，并且占领了药场，把里面的同伴解救了出来啊。第41排第80分钟，凯撒军团又去袭击了动物园。同学们，这里很重要啊，袭击了动物园。
把动物园的那些同伴也解救出来了。
记不记得那场戏啊，我们说之前他有一个伏笔名场面。
他坐在婴儿车里路过动物园，你想一想那场戏是什么？坐在婴儿车里路过动物园，那场戏是何等的优越感啊，你们都不关在笼子里，我有爸爸照顾我，推着婴儿车，推着人类的婴儿车照顾我，对吧？而且在动物园这里，他们还获取武器了啊，他们把那个动物园的那个铁栏杆子给弄成长矛了，我觉得那场戏比较有想象力啊。
是把动物园的那个栏杆卸下来，变成了他们的长毛啊，后面这个战斗要用到代表征服的呃排第一的就是又长又直的大棍子，对吧？长毛嘛，对吧？第42拍啊，81分钟。
这个警察呀和凯撒这个军团啊正式开开战啊，凯撒军团和警察正式开战啊，城市里面打成一片啊，各种各样的战斗场面。然后第43排，凯撒军团有了明呃，就展现出来明确的他们的最终的大决战的目的地，其实就是回到红树林啊，回到红树林，他们向着红树林进发。
然后警察在桥上设置关卡进行大大决战啊，大决战。
然后凯撒指挥他的军团呢兵分三路啊，第44拍也就是86分钟。凯撒军团啊和骑兵队啊骑马的骑兵队短兵相接。凯撒在这个时候依然在阻止依然在阻止。
他的团队杀人，这里还是有一场戏，他阻止也被大猩猩杀人，对吧？制服他们就可以了，不要杀人。
然后威尔呢趁乱进入了战区。
然后与之相对比的啊，就是同学们去看那场戏啊，那场戏其实剪辑还是非常有有比较用心的。凯撒阻止淫背大猩猩杀人，大家记得吧？淫背大猩猩把一个人摁在地上，刚要砸死对方，然后凯撒阻止了他。但是另外一边啊，另外一边人类在射杀。
星醒的时候是毫无思想压力的啊，就是非常干脆利索。就是这个剪辑啊，这个剪辑还是很有意思的啊，很有意思。
然后第45拍89分钟啊，总决战这里总决战这里凯撒骑着战马啊，骑着战马带领大家进攻非常的潇洒啊，非常的潇洒。军团呢就开了杀戒了，在这里啊就不得不开始杀人了啊，军团开始杀人了，然后猩星们啊刚占据上风，然后最难缠的那个最大的那个对手，那个直升机又来了火力压制。那个直升机为什么是最大的对手呢，首先他代表了最最暴力的机器。第二呢，那个直升机上还有谁呀？
不还有那个吗？吊场的那个那个坏老板吗？对吧？然后伤亡很惨重啊，伤亡很惨重。在这个时候啊，银背大猩猩啊跳上了直升机啊，跳上了直升机，舍命救了团队，舍掉自己的命，救了团队啊。然后第46排，我把它单拉出来了啊，单拉出一盘，你也可以不单拉放在警决战里面。
第46拍我单拉出一场就12分钟。
凯撒默许科巴。
杀死了药厂总经理。
记着这几个人啊，凯撒。
就说到了这里，我们的主角依然没有杀人，大家发现没有啊？即便到这里了，我们的主角依然没有杀人，我们掌握的这个尺度很好啊，掌握的这个尺度很好，就是主角到这里了，还没杀人。但是我们也不可能塑到他只是这个是非不分，就是就是个软蛋吧。
他默许科巴干掉了。
基本上也是明士是吧？你这个他他让科巴动手干掉了药厂总经理啊，药厂总经理我们这里把他单拉了一拍啊，然后第47拍故事的最后一拍啊，这个威尔啊趁乱进入战场，我以为他要干点啥呢？结果他们没什么不用，一直在观望啊，一直在观望。
但是最后时刻那个那毕竟是一个象征性的男主角，对吧？象征性的男主角，实际是男2号，他开着这个警车啊，开着这个警车追到了红树林。然后这引着这些星星很不满意要杀了他，但是被凯撒阻止了。然后威尔和凯撒在这里平等对话，两个人平等对话平到什么程度呢？
故意把他俩就就故意把他俩弄得都一般高，你明白我意思吧？就在这里啊，哎看这这场戏。
他把他拉起来。
还是自知道。
其实东位。
You know what they're capable of.
看好吗。
O protect you.
谁知长。
。
再看一下这个名场面啊，也就是说两人告别了之后，凯撒登上树顶，这是这是一场标准的君临天下的戏嘛，代表他成为了丛林之王。但是这场戏非常有意思啊。正常来说，从森林中来到森林中去。
我们说前史啊前史的第一场就在丛林里，然后正式开始戏了之后呢，也是在丛林里，记不记得啊？
我们说假设啊。
假设他的前十到第25分钟，我们说25分钟那里凯撒在哪里啊？
凯撒被。
威尔和。
他女朋友带着在丛林里玩，遇到了那只狗，记不记得啊也是在这片森林，所以说开场从森林从森林开始，结局还是森林。但是。
如果这部片子它不是系列片的第一部。
理论上。
海撒应该俯瞰整片森林。
明白吗？
如果没有后续的故事，凯撒实际上应该俯视整片森林的。因为他说凯撒回家了，家是森林，是红树林。
但是我们看这个名场面啊。
他还是有一半的小心机的，确实是丛林，确实登顶了，确实成为丛林之王了。但是他在俯瞰什么？
但是他俯瞰的却是什么？
他俯瞰的是人类的城市。
也就暗示了后面的故事，他要和人类开战啊，当然了。
这个故事啊金秋崛起系列后续其实没有这一部拍的好啊，不能说没有这一部拍的好吧，是这一部的故事讲的最好啊，这一部的这一部的。
剧作是最好的啊，第一步的剧作是最好的。来，同学们大家都看到了这个片子啊，这个片子非常震撼。我们待会儿再去总结他的一句话故事。我们先来说一下这是个什么片儿，同学们。
首先它是个越狱题材啊，越狱题材呃有一定的越狱成分。所以很多人呢愿意理解为呃被制度化或者是。
那那个那个金羊毛啊，因为有明确目标嘛，还有的同学觉得这两个男主很互补是吧？父亲和儿子的关系，所以说从兄弟情的角度理解也没毛病啊，也没毛病。还有一些同学呢会觉得哎他是他作为一个猩猩在人类社会里，他在前半段想要融入人类社会。
后半段想要建立自己的社会啊，想要离开人类社会，是不是又特别像被制度化？
所以啊如果用斯耐德的10个类型啊，它确实也有点像被制度化。咱们第一次拉的片是不是就是被制度化？肖申克的救赎里面。
我们用前半段。
我们说他前半段想要融入这个监狱，在这个监狱生活的很自在，后半段想要离开这个监狱。我们这个我们这个凯撒呢，他在前他在前半段想要他在故事的终点以前都非常想要回家。
他想要回到人类社会。
然后呢，在后半段呢，他想逃离人类社会，甚至想跟人类社会做对抗。
想要回到人类的社会，新型的社会。
我说在这一点上确实也很像被这的话啊，这个故事是个啥故事，我给大家讲一下啊。
这就是我们为什么要拉这部片子。
我们为什么今天要学习？
为什么今天这节课你又来着了，你又学对了。
因为这个这个这种知识。
咱们关起门来讲，而且我也第一次讲。
斯奈德把所有的故事分成10个种类。
斯奈德的老师是谁？
我之前讲过斯奈德的老师叫坎贝尔。
坦贝尔在1949年就写了一本书，叫千面英雄。
全面英雄。
他讲的不是电影的事儿，他讲的是神话比较学的事儿。但是很多人啊很多人。
看他这本书搞了电影。
包括spec里啊这种大导演，很多人是看。
坦贝尔的书搞了电影。
因为坎贝尔在神话比较学里面把人类共同喜欢听的故事给总结了给总结了。
然后呢，你像斯泰德老师呢，他们就受坎梅尔的启发，然后把神话比较学的这个神学神的这个概念。
啊，神的这个概念呢。
拆分成了10个故事啊，但是。
在坎贝尔的书里面，他认为英雄的故事只有一种。
我来读一下坎贝尔在书里给英雄的定义，同学们听一下啊。
一个英雄。
从平凡的世界进入一个非常的世界。
得到了神话般的力量。
并获取了决定性的胜利。
英雄带着这种能力从神秘的冒险中回来。
和他的同胞和他的同胞。
共享利益。
这就是坎贝尔对英雄故事的定义。
这不就是我们的凯撒。
而且在坎贝尔的定义里面啊。
英雄获取。
魔能力在那里用了一个比喻叫找到了特效药。
同学们。
他在。
他在他的书里啊。
他在写一个英雄获取会获取某种能力。他用了一个比喻，他说这叫找到特效药。
我们这个凯撒真是完美诠释。
完美诠释了千面英雄的理论。
同学们啊，坎贝尔认为世界上的故事只有一种。
然后。
斯奈德读了坎贝尔的书，拆解成了10个故事类型。
然后你有没有发现这个故事在10个故事类型里面卡哪个都不太准，他总是站着好几个是为什么呢？
是因为他是坎贝尔说的那种故事类型。
也就是。
一个人成为神的故事。
我们传送最多的故事就是一个人成为神。
当然了，他们翻译成英雄。所以很多同学说这是不是超级英雄类型，不是啊，肯定不是超级英雄类型的故事。
他就是神的诞生。
这种故事我们理解为王的诞生啊，王的诞生，或者是说叫神的诞生。你可以理解它是故事最原始的形态。所以说我说这个故事。
在写的时候，除了补充细节，肯定要动脑子，在大脉络上绝对就是在致敬致敬千面英雄致敬坎贝尔老师，这个是毫无疑问的啊，这个故事从头到尾在致敬神话，致敬一个凡人成为神，或者是说叫王的诞生。
所以这类故事我们可以理解为就叫王的诞生吧。我们别理解为超级英雄啊，不要因为坎贝尔喜欢把。
把这个这个。
把这些大人物称之为英雄啊，不是啊不是我们就别这么去翻译了。所以我有时候说我说这个翻译很重要啊，咱们影视很多书啊，那些翻译的人他只是懂英文，但是他不懂影视。
经常给我们搞一些很奇怪的翻译，我们给他重新起个名字，叫王的诞生。记不记得我说过王的父亲都不想。
记不记得我说过王都存在绅世问题啊？
王都存在绅实问题啊。
我们这个凯撒完美诠释了。
完美诠释了。
绅士问题。所以说它是一个系列的第一步啊，你可以理解为什么这个第一步啊这如此的规整，如此的好看。
如此的愧疚，如此的好。
从我们的角度啊，我们就借着。
这个故事来温习一下。
坦贝尔的。
私慕式啊坎贝尔的实慕式。
他认为啊一个英雄的征程啊分四段，第一段叫启程啊，放弃当前的处境，进入历险的领域啊。他认为这是英雄的第一步。
英雄的第二步呢就是启蒙啊，就是获得某种引以象征性的方式表达出来的领悟啊，表达出来的领悟。我们这个凯撒的启蒙或者是领悟是非常明确的啊，他领悟到他不是个人啊，人类不是他真正的归属啊。
然后进入考验阶段，就陷入险境与命运搏斗啊，与人类开始大战了啊，就是凯撒的考验，然后最后是归来啊，一定要回到自己的族群当中，回到自己生正常应该生活的一个场域啊，场场地的场那个地狱的域啊，回到自己正常生活的场。
你看翻译这些词儿，它回到自己生活的场景不就完了吗？或者是回到自己的对吧？舒适区不就完了吗？
这就是坎贝尔在。
49年是多少年了啊，N多年了是吧？70多年了，70多年前写下的理论啊，它其实就是一个故事的一个神话啊，最原始的状态。
神话最早所有的神话讲神的诞生。
所以说理解这部电影它是什么类型的，它其实就是讲一个神的诞生啊。当然了，呃人家西方喜欢说是英雄的诞生，没有问题啊，词不重要，你理解一下这种类型的片子。
我们就。
非常清楚这句话，这个这个片子的故事可心了，那就是一个被人类养大了是吧？智商超高的一个星星。
在人类和星星两边摇摆呀，最终决定是吧？重返丛林，成为王者啊，或者是先成为王者，再重返丛林也可以。
总之啊总这个片子的核心故事啊，这个片子给我们最大的一个启示啊，我们学会了写一种类型啊，写一种类型。其实啊其实它就像。
嗯。
哪吒啊哪吒我记得也是差不多是这种套路啊，差不多这种套路。也就是说你在看哪吒的时候，你说你说他是超级英雄吧，你说他是什么吧，死活都卡不上啊。
那我们来看一下，在这部片子当中啊。
主角的。
主角是凯撒，这个没有质疑了吧。这时候你就看那些速看电影，说主角是小帅是有多么的。唉，所以说有时候电影解说号啊，你说这这这这都是哎呀，有一个主角小帅发明了一种什么什么药，然后呢偷摸在那做实验，然后呢呃照顾他的父亲，然后呢，还有他有个星星。
然后他这个星星呢出事了，被人抓走了，然后他想哲去救。
这好家伙这是。
角度完全不对是吧？我们不能光说人家不专业，就说他们嗯不行，不懂，我们要想一下。
他们为什么会这么想？
也就是我们要学一个知识点。
这种片子配角怎么设？
我们要想一下。
这种片子的配角怎么设？为什么会让人误解？
那个是男主角。
小帅是男主角，你看小帅还有爱情呢，还谈恋爱呢，男主角女主角是吧？女主角一共四场戏，吧？那能叫女主角吗？是不是？那我们学什么呢？
为什么设了？
配角这么重的这么重戏份的配角。
为什么？
阿白同学说的非常对，我们需要一个人类视角。
因为在中前期，凯撒连台词都不能说呀。
明白吗？
在整个中前期，凯撒连台词都不能说。虽然他是主角，但是他只要不说台词，实际上他很难完全让观众共情。
明白吧。
所以呢我们要设一个啊跟男主基本上命运共同体的一个配角。但其实啊。
但其实。
配角啊。
这角儿。
在这个戏里面是拆成两个的啊，也就是说它有两个配角。
还有谁啊？
还有小帅，他爹呀。
小帅他爹。
和小帅两个人承担了凯撒伙伴这样一个任务。
这里由于凯撒不能说台词啊，在整个中前期不能说台词，而且他不具备人类视角，所以需要给他设置比较强悍的伙伴来分担这个责任，所以给他设了两个伙伴。
小帅，也就是。
威尔。
另外一个就是威尔的父亲那个阿尔兹海诺的。
老头儿为什么说那个老头也承担了一部分伙伴的责任作用呢？
头。
和凯撒互补。
记没记得？
那个老头儿。
跟凯撒互补。
一个。
得了阿尔兹海默。
什么都记不住的。
人。
隔一个用了特效药。
比人才聪明的。
头儿。
是不是贼互补啊？
别光去嘲笑那些。
解说号说人家不懂电影，你要知道他们为什么走入了这个舞区。你要知道这种片子，他写的时候，他思考他的考量是什么，知其然也知其所以然。为什么他把这两个主角？
呃，他把这两个伙伴搞搞成这么一个配置呢。
是因为他需要有一个跟星星互补，但是呢一是二子海默视角能力也偏弱，而且还是个老头，对吧？商业性不足，那么我们再找一个年轻的。
心里同学说的这句话非常的对。他说凯撒跟老头没啥互动，真可惜，这是我下面要说的。
如果不考虑商业元素。
就考虑剧作。
如果让你写。
你可不可以？
把父亲再强化一下。
把威尔弱化一下。
甚至威尔跟父亲关系没有那么好。
他扔了个星星来照顾父亲，来陪伴父亲。
然后把这个老头戏做。
把老头的死用在高潮西附近。
你想一想这么写行不行？如果不考虑商业元素啊，不考虑我们男主角需要帅气，这是咱们的关门课程。咱们是可以这么去发散性的思考，训练咱们的创作能力的。
我这么说，那杠精们都来了，对吧？家里人家好莱坞编剧不如你。
没事啊，咱们就是启发一下，我也是开放性的告诉你们，你们自己去思考这部片子我们还可以再学一个。
东西啊再学一个东西。我们说这类片子啊。
前十是正常。
这部片子的前十。
长达20多分钟。
同学们咋办？
我是不允许大家写前史的，因为一般来说你们的前十比较无聊，但是这部电影对吧？非常的传统啊，讲一个神的诞生啊，王的诞生。
讲了20接近20多分钟的一个前十。
看的时候没感觉，觉得挺过瘾的，为什么？
是因为这样的片子足够猎奇啊。
他的前十本身就很有趣。
而且他前十的那些事情，人家后面都给你兑现了呀。
有很重要的信息要交代，所以我们得学会一种电影啦。同学们啊，我们要学会一种电影了。
就是古木式啊。
明白吧？
他的前十比那四幕那四幕还长，这部片子一共九十几分钟。
你们作为初学者，我还是非常不建议你们写前十。
明白吧？
呃，我还是非常不建议你们写前十，因为你们写的前十往往就很无聊啊，经常性的很无聊。
就从现状开，尽量锻炼自己，从现状开啊，从现状开场。
当然有特殊情况，你们都是将来如果成为职业写手，那我不拦着。
他是因为有太多东西要交代，所以前面的信息胞非常的。
非常的这个这个这个密集。
在这个故事当中，我们。
着重学两个知识点啊，着重学两个知识点。
第一个知识点啊第一个知识点就是王的诞生这种类型。我们说我们每次拉片啊都要都要学会写一种类型的故事。
我们说这个故事里面啊。
这个故事里面啊。
啊，能够有两种套路我们都可以学啊，我们可以记两种套路。第一种套路就是如何写一个王的诞生啊，这种套路我们以后都要会了。我们如果写一个人的崛起啊，不管他是他妈商业大佬还是黑帮大佬啊，还是说就是一个民间英雄。
都可以参考这部片子的节奏和套路，这就是第一种啊，这就是我们要学的第一件事情。
第二件事情再次强调夸重。
夸中。
跨族群，因为种族族群是人类永恒的话题。
这部片子也好，阿凡达也好，都是靠这个玩意儿啊来震撼心灵的。
同学们可以扩展自己去看一下。你像如果王的诞生，还可以再去参考一下哪吒。
跨种族再去想想阿万达，或者再去看一看第九区。
明白吗？
学会这两种片子的写法。
更重要的是知道啊这个是一种新的类型，或者是说是故事最原始的形态。
同学说老师能再说一下王的诞生的四个阶段吗？哦，就是启程启蒙考验归来。实际跟后面现代商业片发展出来的启程转合差不多，它叫启程启蒙考验归来。
其实差不多，当然更古典一些。其实书上是有12个节拍的啊，但是那个东西就更古典了，你们可以去看一眼。
呃，千面英雄里面的英雄的那个那个平凡世界和特殊世界，两个世界，12个节拍啊，两个世界12个节拍。
但实际上吧确实比较古典啊，有个同学说感觉没拉满，最后没冲突，感觉少了些东西。对。
就是这个问题。所以说人斯奈德在后期人家商业片里面会在后面加上再一次失败，就是再一次痛彻心扉，再一次灵魂，黑夜，再一次被击溃，明白吗？再然后重新成长想办法，但是这里后面比较顺啊，是因为确实是古典主义写法啊。
有同学说，施奈德的理论会不会也随着市场口味慢慢过时了，当然会呀。但是斯奈德的理论是这十年在我们国内电影。
刚刚开始广泛应用，你可以理解我们也。
以美国也是还要稍稍延后的。
说为什么古典写法在。
电影里现在看起来。
更有味道。
也不是呀，古典和现代是可以结合的呀。
并不是说更有味道呀。
有同学说，我们的商业故事创作落后欧美多少年？不不不能这么说不能这么说不能这么说。
我们并不是说落后，我是说延迟。
并不一定是落后啊，是延迟，是因为。
故事审美这个东西它本身是个舶来品啊，电影审美这个东西本身是个舶来品，所以我们被他们牵着鼻子走很正常。那既然被人牵着走，那滞后一点。
但不代表我们水平低啊。
那今天就到这儿吧。
下课。
。